so can you tell me
what you think is social media so maybe
say this company that company this
company social media what is social
media to you
you know typically when i'm using the
term i'm thinking about attention
economy platforms
where your data time and attention is
the primary product the primary thing
they're extracting to sell
and i make a distinction between social
media and the social internet i'm a big
early booster of the internet and the
social internet i think using the
internet for
expression and connection is very
important so it's really that
attention manipulation aspect it's a
large platform closed garden
trying to extract monetize your data
your attention so that would be
uh you know it's hard to keep up with
but the classics would be facebook it'd
be twitter it would be instagram
it would be tick tock on the other hand
things like there's there's really
hazy dividing lines instant messenger
services probably not
whatsapp right whatsapp is sort of
they're trying to be more like
a social network but it's it's in its
own sort of in-between space for example
uh group text messages is not obviously
things like being on a podcast or
something
is not right youtube i don't know how to
think about it
you know i because youtube is a very
complicated thing it is the best
video is incredibly important it's a
great platform from it but they have
this recommendation engine which is
trying to grab your attention but it so
like i think youtube is in a weird space
right so it's not super clear-cut some
things
are i think twitter's pretty clear-cut i
think facebook's pretty clear-cut
i don't know how to think about youtube
i don't know how to think about whatsapp
you know
i don't have to think about clubhouse
like what is clubhouse i don't really
know
i'm doing a clubhouse you know shortly
with a
a tech reporter from the new york times
to see what it is because i don't even
know what that is
so it's not an easy question to answer
got it so do you watch youtube
i mean not a lot but i'm fascinated by
youtube because i think
democratizing video is incredibly
important and it seems to be really the
only
game in town right if i'm understanding
obviously you you're a master of the
medium
there really isn't a co is this true
there's not really a comparable platform
that makes it
that's so good at uh hosting video and
displaying video and you can play in all
these different
uh tablets and tvs and phones
and um so yeah i use i use youtube often
like a library when i'm trying to look
something up or want to see okay
yeah exactly or there's a someone i'm
interested in i want to see them
interviewed
um i you know so i'm very interested in
youtube i don't i don't know quite how
to think about it but i think it's
something very important happening there
well you you seem very sincere and
almost
like an innocent way of thinking and a
very clear set of
uh uh standards on what you will
classify as social media now some would
say youtube is a social media company
second largest you know on traffic etc
etc and you're right there's not
necessarily comparable to them
vimeo some of these other companies
facebook may say yes we are
direct competitor of youtube maybe on
short clips facebook's not big on long
form like you're not going to see too
many three-hour podcasts
on facebook instagram may say we also
get on the short
videos one minute two minute five
minutes 10 minutes
not necessarily our type of thing so so
then that
uh goes back to twitter facebook
instagram
being ones that you have a challenge
with and it's is it
mainly because they get to dictate
what you watch next and they're able to
trigger
and kind of manipulate the whole thing
to say hey cal you like this let me feed
you some more of this hey like
the whole social dilemma documentary i'm
assuming that's the part that you
uh uh don't see any value in using those
social media platforms is that a good
uh a way of putting it well i mean i
want it i want to put it so starkly so
so again the way i think about things
through
my digital minimalism perspective is
there's not something i really value in
life for which any of those platforms
is a really big win the thing i'm very
wary of is what
in another book i wrote i called the any
benefit mindset i think especially with
tech it's very dangerous to approach
tech from the ask the mindset of could
there be some value here
if so why don't i try it in some
settings that's okay
it's nice to explore but because of the
things you're talking about that's a
dangerous decision in the world of these
social media networks because
innocently let me just like do some
instagram might end up being
seven hours a day it might end up being
i am on this way more than i think it's
useful way more than i think is healthy
so
you have to be a little bit more wary
with these platforms because they are
very good at grabbing your attention
once they're there so i keep coming back
to look if there's a big win i'll use it
but
it could be interesting you could find
some new readers there might be
something interesting
that's not going to be compelling enough
for me especially when there's so many
of these attention traps that have been
engineered into the services so i'm very
wary
cal do any of your family members uh use
social media probably yeah i'm not sure
which platforms but
i mean i think i'm the only person
between the age of 20 and 45
left in this country uh who doesn't use
social media so
i think i can confidently i think ahmet
you know i mean i
i think when they have board meetings at
facebook and they have audience
acquisition charts there's only one
thing left on it which is a picture of
me
all right we're almost done we're almost
done so what do you what do you keep
pictures where do you keep pictures of
family like albums
uh on my phone so which which by the way
is i think a probably a strategic
mistake that was made by the major
platforms
is starting around 2012 to 2015 they
said we're
going to shift away from the original
premise which is this is a place to
connect with people you know and we're
going to switch instead towards a news
feed model we are going to use
algorithmic information to get you a
steady stream of things that's going to
be
engaging to you and a lot of people just
migrated things like sharing photos with
their family they're like well fine i'm
not going to do this on facebook i'm
going to do it on a group
text message chain i think ultimately
that's probably going to be an issue for
these platforms because if they lose
their
network effect advantage if it doesn't
matter to me whether or not my cousin is
on facebook because i can just send him
a picture of my kids
on imessage now facebook's
advantage why i have to use that
platform gets way reduced once it
becomes just a source of entertainment
yeah it's a stream of stuff that
algorithms are selecting it's engaging
it's competing with every other form of
entertainment out there
much more competitive landscape so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye